[Musique]
bonjour bonjour qu'est ce qu'on fait
mérité aujourd'hui deux petites choses
délicieuses est très simple vous allez
voir on va faire d'abord le tour en
livrant ce qu'est ce que c'est que ça ça
c'était pour elle c'est une soupe qu'on
mange le soir quand on arrive d'avoir
fait la fête et quand on est un peu chez
lui mais on fait un tour un ivrogne
c'est-à-dire avait bien de l'oignon et
vous allez voir simple on fait un bond
de chabrot et puis en blanc peut dormir
non après alors vous allez voir que tu
as l'air car en fait ce que maïté
appelle le tour à un lebron c'est une
des recettes les plus traditionnelles
qui soit
les mousquetaires bien entendu on
prenait très souvent mais c'est une
recette traditionnelle qui se perd et
c'est bien pourquoi que ça valait bien
la peine de vous la montrer
et c'est dommage et puis ensuite et bien
qu'est ce qu'on fera ensuite il ya des
lapins c'est pas il ya un vrai on va
faire du lapin à l'armagnac ses très
bons aussi eh bien on va commencer
peut-être par le tourin à poigne
voilà beaucoup pour l'oignon en fines
lamelles vous allez me convient un peu
plus de 200 départs la quantité qu'on
fait il faut pas que ce soit le plus
raide omnium il faut que galea c'est
quand même alors pour la quantité d'eau
vous allez voir que je vais mettre j'ai
mis deux jolis petits oignons très bien
voilà bon et on va ensuite on va mettre
ma graisse de canard de canard dans la
poêle oui là de petites cuillères parce
que trois les trois cuillères à soupe
oui il faut voir là après on prend
lorient il ne faut pas laisser il faut
laisser blondir tout doucement quand
même et un sens au cul par il faut pas
qu'ils vous il faut pas qu'il y ait de
l'humour noir
ces points et lisa de la recette faut
faire attention à l'oignon mais de toute
façon de tout ce qu il faut faire
attention avec munich pour la surveiller
et wyeth en tout cas là vous ne disiez
que c'était le tour un divan tron mais
il ya beaucoup de tours indifférent dans
votre région il ya le tourin à l'ail il
ya tout un atome à fond et ça c'est le
tour est un ivrogne sur trois souffre
vous savez c'est trop souple où les
hommes ici fort chabrol et que tu ne
fais que de faire chabrot à faire
chabrot c'est délicieux parce que la
dernière en s on mais on met les
assiettes c
cette soupe que dans les assiettes
creuses et puis on mange pas dans la
soupe dans des assiettes pour ce live
house s'est ouvert ce matin les
assiettes creuses
la cites bien là alors on met le truc et
puis à l'appeler à la faire on est un
peu de jus au fond de mes tripes on
prend le bus vers toulouse du vin rouge
et au pas la cuillère et on prend la
bouteille l'assiette est en travaux je
vous assure les hommes se régale moi je
dois dire que j'adore j'adore ça parce
que les femmes en général on met les
hommes il se régale c'est la seule issue
pour faire je vais salle est un tout
petit peu le poids de l'oignon du poivre
à plouvien non pas sur le poivron va le
mettre dans la danse alors là maintenant
on va se donner notre poule est ouvert
on va y mettre du sel gros rue rue sur
des poivres aussi du bien sûr la force
sera s'est relevé comme il faut que ce
soit très relevé là je vous dis il faut
que ça fasse bourge eu la bonne idée
quand on revient d'une nuit un peu
chaude voix les mains voilà au ksar a
qu'un petit peu à la gorge
alors on va laisser vient de dire ça on
va faire bouillir notre sel notre salle
et on va surveiller
les oignons maïté mois me paraissent
très bien ils sont traités rendu
impeccable
j'adorais alors maintenant eh bien voilà
je voulais pas du tout à l'heure mais
maintenant on va mettre un soupçonne de
vinaigre dans ses oignons oui pas
beaucoup et il faut pas mettre tous mes
petits fils et un petit filet de l'arbre
roi là et on va remuer ça ça donne un
parfum et le goût délicieux à l'oignon
il a regardé comme se plaisent et à
l'art inuit est bien en vie de tous la
grèce et tout est dans l'aude à riante
et on va laisser cuire et on va laisser
bouillir oui oui on va inventer un petit
peu le feu on va laisser vous lire la
bible minutes et bono social va
peut-être nous permettre de couper le
panneau on va continuer la colère si on
va préparer la suite la voilà la savak
tranquillement on va prendre le perdre
et on va faire des soupes
on appelle ça oui je vais vous apprendre
beaucoup de choses aujourd'hui
on n'appelle pas du père on me demandera
sous peu et c'est une tranche de pain
depuis deux tranches de pain de campagne
kampala parce que là il est gros et on
fait les soupes
voilà comme ça et même me donnez moi le
père s'est même pas comme ça qu'on fait
là on fait les soupes carrément avait le
pen donc jusqu'au plateau là et croyez
moi que tous les personnes âgées les
vieux comme on dit chez nous ils vont
être ravis de me voir faire ça parce que
ça fait la vraie trame c'est la vraie
tradition avait la même grandeur de paix
qu'on faisait autrefois donc secours
mais grandir à dubaï et à partir de ce
crime temps là comme ça dans tous les
sens taillée en fait
alors vous voyez j'avais commencé là on
fait tourner le pen pour pas perdre un
tour d'un côté et la d'égaliser et voilà
et en os mais une bonne quantité un jour
oui c'est ça se nourrissant mais quand
vous savez quand on arrive de faire la
fête on à faire là voilà c'est tout
ensuite on légalise le pen on met là
dessus du gruyère assez mais pas pour
quand même voilà
ces taux et après on prend notre soupe
oui il doit être excellentes et je la
verse dans la terrine voilà regardez
comme les jolies regarder la couleur que
là ça c'est un vrai pour air le vrai de
vrai et personne ne peut me de
contredire la la et alors là là ça c'est
pour rire et qui a fait un bon dîner qui
rentrait à la maison un peu fatigués ou
qu'ils matin sa salle havre et s'arrête
alors là on remet du gruyère dessus et
on passe au four on passe au four le
timbre pour très précieux ils rêvent
show et pendant ce temps pendant que ça
gratis nous allons pouvoir nous occuper
du lapin
[Musique]
je termine de le couper en petits
morceaux voilà là pour dire que c'est
beau lapin donc à de bons morceaux
journée j'ai voulu leur est ce que vous
allez en faire management marcellin
maintenant on va faire dorer ses
morceaux à la cocotte dans de la graisse
j'imagine dans de la graisse viennent
enlever voulait passer voilà qui est
chose nous attend donc ça va griller
très vite
oui la tâche est très bonne voilà les
morceaux joli morceau
mettez les morceaux nobles non notre
joli morceau les morceaux nobles c'est à
dire les bornes et vous les moments le
râble avec le jeudi rognon la meuse où
les et je laisse les têtes on verra plus
tard si on a le temps dans l'hudson
voilà plus bolt à pékin de laisser dorer
toute sa classe et de grottes et des
biens s'est muée bon sens bb c'est vrai
que de les saler et poivrer
le tout merci mais je serai le dos ou un
rôdeur assez douces qui nous sommes à
paris la seine et souliers ont bondi
avec moi j'attends vraiment me sentir
une importance plus grande
oui vous le faites chez vous oui les
couleurs et les gardiens ont salué
l'adresse était bien seul voilà et ont
un petit peu de scène et on va pouvoir
peut-être que s'occuper de quoi renvoie
la laisser on va s'occuper de la vente
ce n'est pas fini on va les laisser à
des coups un peu là voilà comme ça mais
pour que ça dort oui maintenant on va
couper la ventrèche très fine notre vin
chaud toujours mais que vous prenez
parce que elle et a touché l'île est
grand mais qu elle est très belle
regardez ça leur enfant un petit peu
poivrez ali ou bien et les zones et du
tour élite assaisonner et les salles et
pour avoir mis la pagaille et bien sûr
ya ce qu'il faut et les bonnes et les
bonnes dans du pain bien fruits un bon
sandwich c'est délicieux la voilà alors
maintenant je vais aller sortir les mots
sur de la peine ils sont pendant que
vous allez pas relevé le plastique
pousserait jean ping oui moi je vais
sortir les morceaux de la ferme ça je
vais le vide et je vais le mettre là
allez non là on va sentir dans la ferme
contre la presse grandes économies sont
ici
reste à faire se lever mais ça va aller
pour se savoir ap ap après oui vous
inquiétez pas ça va être bien payé sa
maman je suis prête
vous la donne pour la scène un petit lit
de ventrèche au fond entrant au tiers en
tranche entière un lit devrait pas être
mauvais le mélange des entrait chez de
bias de sens comme un petit peur du tout
non c'est bon c'est bon mais il faudra
couper encore lewis
on va savoir pourquoi alors ensuite on
met le lit de la ferme et saler poivrer
on manque un peu plus oui c'est bien à
deux c'est toujours mieux
on va mettre notre lit de la paire saler
poivrer
la voilà et j'imagine que vous allez
remettre une couche de l'art par dessus
oui je me suis pas trompé hier sur une
autre couche bien gentil parce que
c'était après ça va vous donner un
parfum là dedans ça va vous avez sans
doute pu être encore un petit peu je
crois là alors l'amener ensuite on va
mettre du thym du laurier des quatre
épices alors le teint les branches de
ferme
le laurier du laurier forme a coûté 4
épices les quatre épices gingembre
gironcel et muscade
voilà pourquoi danger un joli brin de
personnes soupçonnent la ville pour les
nas et c'est peut-être été un peu
généreuse le n'ont pas beaucoup de boue
soit menacée par la saison en juillet
dans le plus le goût est alors
maintenant maintenant saisons maintenant
vous finir la saison j'en devine
l'armagnac qui vous notre éternelle
armagnac l'armagnac dans le vide en
forme
s'agace la guerre
voilà et on va flamber le tout
et notre petit sucre quand je dis va se
faire voilà et tout ça va flamber et
cuire un bon moment et lui un bon
maintenant il faudra plus de 300 parce
que là reuters toru hanai il a tapé do
ré eh bien on voit mon petit lapin à
tout à l'heure
[Musique]
et bien voilà lapin qui est servi we do
ré mettrait temps oui avec les petits
morceaux de lard quand même bien
croustillant qu'est-ce qui nourrirent
bout
alors on va mettre le juge en a pas
beaucoup et bien sûr c'est très signaler
lui un bon petit jus on ap
cela fait de ce but là et vous m'en
direz des nouvelles
cet appétissant très près la soupe
palace en valeur ça c'est la meilleure
voie la gratuité vous avez le tour l
ivrogne et trouver un livre nyala voilà
on coupe le grade terne là et le jus et
laon de celle de lenovo vient je vous
assure c'est délicieux alors voilà
allez-y
si vous avez la paix vous prenez ça au
petit matin après une nuit chaude si
vous avez moins d'appétit ça vous fait
dîner du soir
alors à vous d'essayer nos idées du soir
et de sang pourquoi pas bonne soupe
comme ça je veux avec ravi et à bientôt
à pouvoir voir à tous
[Musique]